[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du grand jt des territoires sur
vos chaînes locales et régionales de la
tnt et sur tv5 monde voici tout de suite
les titres de l'actualité de cette
édition avec ce que vivent 19 c'est une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre que l'on
constate partout en cette période de
pandémie embauchait est devenu mission
impossible ou presque comme a pu le
constater une équipe de tl7 la
télévision de la loire la baguette low
cost dans ce journal voilà une
initiative qui passe mal celles des
supermarchés leclerc qui propose une
baguette à 29 centimes seulement nous
entendre et dans ce journal les
réactions des professionnels de la
filière recueillis par nos confrères de
tele7 à la chaîne du groupe sud ouest à
bordeaux et puis dans ce journal le
système des parrainages remise en
question vous le savez sont les
candidats qui auront récolté les
fameuses 500 signatures de maires
pourront se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
une règle qui a ses limites comme vous
allez pouvoir le voir dans ce reportage
de vosges télévision
et puis à la fin de ce journal vous
verrez les toutes premières images d'un
taxi volant que l'on doit à la chaîne
via 95 taxi qui pourrait être mise en
service à l'horizon 2024 finalement vous
constaterez avec nous que le futur c'est
demain
pénurie d'intérimaires trains annulés
chantier ralenti voire repoussée pour
cause d'employés malades ou déclaré qu'à
contacter c'est une des conséquences du
coc vite de 19 et comme je vous le
disais en titre les agences d'intérim
peine à trouver de la main d'oeuvre
comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage de céline r s'il ya de tl7 la
chaîne de la loire garder
dans cette société de carrelage l'année
commence plutôt bien les carnets de
commandes se remplissent seul problème
il manquerait un peu de main d'oeuvre
pour réaliser les chantiers une équipe
de douze personnes et déjà une personne
qui était qu'à contacter plus quand j'ai
demandé à la société de thomas intérim
pour l'intérêt des élus des choses aussi
qui qui a pas pu être présent comme il
l'aurait voulu a donné des personnes
pour ses collaborateurs parce qu'il y
avait des cas contactez coville pourquoi
tout le monde demont a touché le chef
d'entreprise a dû apprendre à jongler et
doit régulièrement expliquer les retards
de chantier à ses clients la société
pourrait facilement prendre quatre ou
cinq intérimaires mais là aussi il ya un
manque les entreprises sont à l'affût de
tous les profils qui se présente comme
ici un candidat sans expérience qui veut
se reconvertir dans un travail
d'extérieur qu'on leur proposait dans
cette entreprise 11
en ce moment la crise du coc vide plombe
l'émission mais il ya derrière une vraie
problématique pour une énorme demande et
on est pénalisé les entreprises seront
pénalisés par le
parlement de salariés
qu'on arrivera à détacher mais à la
sortie de cette crise et je sais pas
quand est-ce que ce sera
nous verrons bien mais le
problème le problème aujourd'hui je
pense que le colis de cache un peu la
face l arbre qui cache un peu la forêt
quoi cette agence d'intérim tente de
couvrir les besoins d'une centaine
d'entreprises sur son bassin mais une
quarantaine de missions restent encore à
pourvoir et le phénomène pourrait bien
perdurer même en fin de crise sanitaire
voilà et puis de l'aéronautique à la
santé il n'ya qu'un pas qu'a franchi une
entreprise installée avarie en ariège le
groupe leader mondial du rivet
aéronautique a fait un virage à 180
degrés et produits aujourd'hui 600
masques chirurgicaux à la minute une ré
industrialisation en somme réussi salué
par agnès pannier rue nash et la
ministre déléguée chargée de l'industrie
que jonathan donzé devient occitanie a
pu interviewer regarder un champion de
l'industrie aéronautique reconverti dans
la production de masques lusine hachage
et médical s'est lancé dans leur
fabrication et compte devenir d'ici
moins de 10 ans le leader mondial de
cette nouvelle filière notre métier
historique et la bêtise à faire le camp
de masque et c'est là où ça nous avait
sauté aux yeux on a dit c'est vraiment
ça c'est vraiment le même métier c'est
ce qu'on sait faire c'est un produit à
aider fort volume de la technicité et
peu de marge pour diversifier son
activité l'entreprise a été aidée par
l'état à hauteur de 3 millions 5 ce qui
a permis l'investissement dans une
quarantaine de machines de quoi produire
aujourd'hui 600 masquer la minute c'est
un très bel exemple ici de montrer qu'on
peut passer de l'aéronautique à la santé
ça c'est pas du tout la même production
c'est pas du tout la même matière c'est
pas du tout les mêmes machines mais
c'est la même logique de fonctionnement
de rigueur de recherche de performance
de travail de développement d'innovation
les principaux clients son aval groupe
airbus et de nombreuses cliniques et
pharmacie hachage et médical produit
actuellement 30 millions de masques
chirurgicaux par mois le projet
permettra à terme la création de 150
emplois
voilà et puis c'est la polémique du
moment tout le monde en a parlé cette
semaine vous le savez les supermarchés
leclerc ont proposé une baguette à 29
centimes d'euros contre 90 centimes en
moyenne dans les boulangeries
traditionnelles agapes milstein de tv7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest s'est
rendu dans la région bordelaise
recueillir les réactions de
professionnels à ce qui s'apparente à un
véritable coup de com regardez
un symbole de la tradition française au
coeur du débat actuellement le prix
moyen d'une baguette et de 90 centimes
mais au nom de la défense du pouvoir
d'achat des français le patron des
magasins leclerc a décidé de bloquer le
prix de ce produit à 29 centimes pour
beaucoup de professionnels de la filière
ce choix est vécue comme une déclaration
de guerre ce boulanger lui relativise ça
n'a strictement rien à voir ni la façon
de faire n'est leur passion de ni le
goût ni rien qui est incomparable les
clients et continue quand même à
venir et à
à consommer ce qui est bon la farine
qu'utilisent les enseignes de
distribution n'est pas la même que celle
destinée aux boulangeries artisanales ce
qui explique le prix compétitifs elle
serait de moins bonne qualité si michel
edouard leclerc se justifie en voulant
défendre un symbole ainsi que le pouvoir
d'achat des français pour les syndicats
d'agriculteurs c'est une manière de
détruire leur valeur quoi qu'il arrive
tous les efforts que peuvent faire les
producteurs français sur la qualité
en ayant ce genre de communication du
moins disant c'est pas une bonne image
ça c'est sûr c'est probablement une
concurrence déloyale
est ce que vraiment c'est à prix coûtant
ou est-ce que c'est pas une forme de
distorsion de concurrence
une moins bonne qualité peut-être mais
certainement un gros coup de
communication pour un produit qui a
toujours autant de succès en france 320
baguettes sont produites et consommées
chaque seconde
voilà et puis sans transition la
politique avec la récente défection
d'arnaud montebourg il reste quarante
trois candidats à l'élection
présidentielle et je vous le disais pour
pouvoir se présenter à la magistrature
suprême chacun d'entre eux doivent se
munir des précieux parrainage les 500
signatures de maires une règle établie
en 1965 de plus en plus questionné par
les élus eux mêmes quand vous allez voir
dans ce sujet signé aurélie colombelles
de vosges télévision
le 27 janvier prochain s'ouvre le
recueil des parrainages pour les
élections présidentielles les candidats
déclarés ont jusqu'au 4 mars pour
recueillir 500 signatures d'élus
répartis sur tout le territoire et
provenant d'au moins 30 départements on
est on est assailli il faut bien le dire
parce que y comme jeudi 50 c'est
peut-être plus un candidat potentiel à
cette à cette élection présidentielle la
maire de nomexy 2000 habitants en reçoit
plusieurs par semaine on sait par
courriel c'est très informel donc et
c'est une présentation synthétique avec
des liens des fois qu'ils renvoient sur
des programmes ou pas alors après savoir
s'ils sont constitués en équipes on peut
supposer que les candidats les majors
ils sont bien structurés organisés pour
avoir des équipes et les autres le 10
candidats dont on ne connaît pas le nom
auront beaucoup plus de mal à se
structurer députés sénateurs conseillers
régionaux départementaux présidents
d'intercommunalités et mères peuvent
apporter leurs signatures à ce jour
sollicité en tant que maire mais pas
sous sa casquette de conseillère
départementale
martine joulia ne compte pas offrir son
parrainage j'ai été élu en tant qu en ma
qualité de maire pour porter un
programme et un projet pour une cause et
collectivités donc la commune de la
ville de nommer xi pour pour un
territoire et pas pour un territoire
national à cela s'ajoute pour certains
la crainte de subir des représailles
dans les urnes des pressions de parti ou
du chantage des collectivités parena ce
n'est que le permettra une pensée
politique de pouvoir exister dans la
campagne présidentielle c'est moi c'est
pas toujours perçu comme cela c'est
perçu pour dire ah bah oui lui soutient
ce sont les petits candidats ou ce sens
ramifications territoriales qui peinent
à obtenir des quarante mille élus une
signature alors comment permettre une
représentation des idées
jean luc mélenchon propose un parrainage
citoyen autre solution on pourrait
envisager d'élargir le nombre de gens
susceptibles de donner les parrainages
et pourquoi ne pas alors permettre que
la diversité des conseillers municipaux
qui sont tous des élus de la république
puisse conduire à parrainer des gens qui
ne sont pas forcément à la tête des
communes lors de la dernière élection
4000 et lui avaient apporté un
parrainage en dehors de leur parti reste
un dernier blocage et non des moindres
celui de la capacité à financer une
campagne présidentielle voilà et puis
toujours la politique at-on cramer la
caisse comme valérie pécresse l'a
souligné dans ses interventions de
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
en tout cas cette semaine olivier du
soft est l invité de face aux
territoires sur tv5 monde l'occasion
pour le ministre délégué chargé des
comptes publics de faire quelques
annonces et de répondre à valérie
pécresse comme vous allez voir
valérie pécresse a ordonné bronze le
tout ce qu'il faut il a dit l'autre soir
à la télévision sauf les malades ou en
grèce donc elle dit qu'elle aurait
dépensé madame pécresse à un bal comme
vous madame pécresse a un bilan le bilan
de madame pécresse cantat était ministre
du budget c'est le vote de la loi pour
2012 ses 15 milliards d'augmentation
d'impôts essai suivi par cinq années de
croissance à 0 de baisse du pouvoir
d'achat et donc quand madame pécresse
nos 10 ans cram la caisse alors que
c'est la même qui demande et qui obtient
deux milliards et demi d'euros dead
quand elle parle de l'augmentation des
impôts alors que nous avons baissé de 50
milliards et qu' elle même les avaient
augmenté de 15 milliards d'euros quand
elle parle de santé alors que si
lorsqu'a été mises l'enseignement
supérieur elle avait fait ce que nous
avons fait c'est à dire supprimer
numerus clausus si elle l'avait fait au
moment où il était ministre
l'enseignement supérieur nous aurions
quinze mille médecins de plus donc elle
un bilan il à son désavantage il faut
qu'elle assume en voilà et puis nous
partons pour l'isère maintenant en
france on dénombre en moyenne 151
médecins généralistes pour 100 mille
habitants mais tous les départements ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne
l'heure est celui qui en comptent le
moins et les hautes-alpes le plus et
pour tenter de lutter contre le problème
des déserts médicaux certains
s'organisent comme en isère qui a lancé
un dispositif qui pourrait bien donner
des idées à d'autres explications avec
lorie bayer de télégrenoble à regarder
l'isère n'échappe à la règle comme
partout en france la profession médicale
vieilli pour lutter contre les déserts
médicaux et faciliter l'accès aux soins
le département de l'isère a lancé en
2017 izard médecin un dispositif qui
veut inciter les internes en médecine
générale et les médecins à s'installer
dans le département or le dispositif isr
médecin c'est un dispositif qui permet
de faciliter l'implantation de médecins
généralistes sur le département avec
plusieurs actions une première action
qui est celle d'apporter une bourse
d'études de cinquante six mille euros
aux internes en médecine et en
contrepartie ils doivent s'installer
pour 570 jour sur le département ensuite
il ya une action qui est menée au niveau
des médecins installés déjà pour qu'ils
deviennent maîtres de stage et
permettent aux internes de sortir de
l'hôpital et de faire des stages sur
l'ensemble du département au cours de
leur cursus universitaire et puis enfin
il y a bien sûr les aides que nous
apportons aux
maison médicale et 700000 euros qui sont
apportées aux porteurs de projet en
quatre ans ce dispositif a motivé 132
médecins à venir exercer dans le
département comme le docteur lola
d'audel qui s'est installée à meylan en
2020 j'ai 800 patients déclarés plus
évidemment des patients qu'on dépense
pour des urgences à en reste accessible
pour les urgences j'avais besoin de
m'ancrer à un endroit de faire du suivi
d'être le médecin de famille et je
partage l'espace avec une autre médecin
généraliste des kinés des dentistes et
un dermatologue comme la ville de meylan
421 une commune du département sont
éligibles au dispositif selon les
critères de cette médecin généraliste
pour 10000 habitants avec un âge moyen
de 55 ans
voilà et puis nous nous rendons du côté
de cholet maintenant où il ya quelques
semaines une pme du maine et loire
spécialisée en équipement des véhicules
pour l'auto école et pour l'adaptation
andy conduite a été choisi par citroën
pour équiper son modèle a mis 100 %
électrique dont vous découvrez des
images signées et lise denis de tlc la
télévision locale du choletais comme je
vous disais
voilà et puis du côté de la loire
atlantique cette fois ci une salle de
classe équipées de vélo d'appartement ou
encore de ballons de gymnastique le
concept peut paraître étonnant et
pourtant il fait ses preuves depuis
quelques années le lycée de
chateaubriand a voulu expérimenter ce
qu'on appelle la classe flexibles les
élèves étudient en mouvement et c'est un
réel bénéfice pour leur concentration
comme a pu le constater sur place b a
bâti de télénantes
je suis sur un ballon de gym et du coup
ça me permet de faire des petits
mouvements pour ça fait un petit peu et
puis même pour garder un peu le dos
droit et puis comme si une personne qui
aime beaucoup bougé ça me permet de ce
que les buts quand je suis sur ma chaise
à bout d'une heure va ce j'en ai un peu
marre et j'ai envie de sortir du coup là
ça me permet de bouger et de rester en
place une des vélos bureau des ballons
jim des poufs et même des tapis de sol
contre toute attente nous sommes bien
dans une salle de classe ces lycéennes
sont en terminale accompagnement soins
et services à la personne odyssée moquer
le noir de châteaubriant et depuis la
rentrée elle profite de cette salle de
classe flexible je pense que c'est une
bonne idée parce que ça nous permet de
ne pas de travailler en étant tous
ensemble donc c'est plutôt conviviale ça
nous permet d'être assis dans une autre
position qu être acheté sur une chaise
toute la journée la salle de classe
flexibles ce concept vient des états
unis l'aménagement et le mobilier
permettent aux élèves d'apprendre et de
travailler en mobilité odyssée manqué le
noir deux enseignantes s'en sont
inspirés pour répondre aux besoins de
leurs élèves on a pu constater quand
même que nos élèves avaient du mal à
garder la posture statique assise sur
une chaise derrière un bureau que
beaucoup bougé beaucoup sur les chaises
et avaient du mal à rester concentré en
fait tout le temps nécessaire donc petit
à petit on est arrivé on a commencé à
proposer à certains élèves qui étaient
vraiment
en demande de mouvements de travailler
debout contre un contre un meuble et on
a pu constater quand même les résultats
bénéfiques des évaluations nettement
meilleure les deux enseignantes effectué
des recherches obtiennent une subvention
de 7000 euros et la classe flexible voit
le jour en septembre dernier après
quatre mois d'expérimentation les
bénéfices sont déjà visibles que ce soit
en cours classique ou en exercice dirigé
une meilleure concentration et plus de
convivialité la salle flexible est pour
le moment uniquement utilisé par les
sections professionnelles
ledit s'est moqué le noir de
châteaubriant envisage déjà d'en créer
une nouvelle pour les filières générales
voilà et puis du côté de troyes
maintenant il ya tout juste dix ans ian
nicholas et jacques henry trois
étudiants en école de commerce créé
l'association la cravate solidaire pour
lutter contre la discrimination à l
embauche depuis plusieurs centaines ont
été ouvertes en france dont une
installée depuis un an à pont sainte
marie dans l'aube où s'est rendu pour
nous merrill loisel de canal tron d'
l'habit ne fait pas le moine mais il y
contribue
c'est le leitmotiv de la cravate
solidaire une association qui lutte
contre les discriminations à l'embauché
liées à l'apparence l'idée c'est donc de
valoriser les personnes
par rapport à leur image et puis dans le
choix de leur donner confiance en elle
pour passer leur entretien dans most
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
at en fait on les accueille dans le
dressing dans lequel elles sont
accompagnées on leur propose de trois
tenues en fonction en fait de leur
personnalité de l'emploi pour lequel
elles vont postuler et au delà du
conseil en image la quarantaine de
bénévoles proposent aussi une expertise
en ressources humaines des bureaux
dédiés permettent aux bénéficiaires de
s'entraîner à passer un entretien de
présenter un entretien sous une forme ou
sous une autre nécessite de la
préparation et nécessite de
l'entraînement et c'est sur ces points
très particulier que nous insistons que
ce soit pour réfléchir la veille au soir
à ce que nous allons dire que ce soit
pour chercher
le trajet que nous allons prendre pour
nous y rendre
c'est une manière d'arriver plus serein
lors d'un entretien un studio photo
complète ces ateliers coup de pouce pour
que les demandeurs d'emploi s'approprie
jusqu'au bout leur apparence et les
orienter pour les aider à prendre une
photo pour leur cv et pour leurs réseaux
sociaux professionnels s'il en est
l'antenne auboise a vu le jour il ya un
an et 85 personnes ont déjà pu profiter
de ses services pour 2022 l'association
veut expérimenter des ateliers connectés
et recherche également des bénévoles
pour permettre à ceux qui en ont besoin
de continuer à croire en eux
voilà donc l'appel est lancé pour plus
d'informations rendez vous sur le site
de la cravate solidaires.org
ils sont vingt mille en france je veux
parler des trufficulteurs et des nains
chien ou d'un cochon il cherche
inlassablement ce qu'on surnomme les
perles noires autrement dit la truffe et
avant que la saison de la truffe ne
sache avant février manon aussi la
veinarde de la dépêche de l'unido
partenaires sur place s'est rendu dans
le lot pour faire la connaissance de
jean jacques fourès et de puces son
cochon regarder
de ma plus jeune enfance j'ai toujours
qu'avec un cochon mon père dresser les
cochons utilisable et donc que tous les
amoureux avaient cherché truffe avec le
cochon depuis 30 ans
les gens préfèrent préféré dresser les
chiens parce que les chiens on le garde
or une dizaine d'années alors que le
cochon il faut dresser tous les arts
davantage ce qu'avait avec un cochon
c'est que lui ne ramasse que d'être
figure 1 alors que le chien galeux les
plus faibles toutes les truffes qui va
sentir qui veut ça commence à sentir
légèrement eelv a voulu lever
voilà sans transition le 30 décembre
dernier simon lopez jeunes
clarinettistes de 16 ans remporté la
finale de l'émission prodige sur france
2 de retour dans sa haute savoie natale
l'adolescente s'est confié devant la
caméra de victoria lopes de 8 mont blanc
écoutons là
[Musique]
elle est rarement mise au premier plan
la clarinette demande beaucoup de
travail de souffle et de détermination
elle a séduit simon dès son plus jeune
âge donc j'ai découvert cet instrument
dans un cd audio piccolo saxo et
compagnie donc que j'écoutais quand
j'étais plus petit et bah non c'est dans
ce cd en fait tous les instruments de
leurs questions rencontre au fur et à
mesure et à chaque fois un petit air et
jouer j'ai vraiment beaucoup apprécié le
son la clarinette donc j'ai commandé une
clarinette pour l'anniversaire de mes
sept ans et après je me suis inscrit
dans une école de musique presque dix
ans plus tard six mois a remporté la
finale de l'émission prodige diffusé sur
france 2 suivi par plus de 3 millions de
téléspectateurs cette soirée a permis au
jeune homme de faire connaître son
instrument au grand public qu'on dit je
l'avais aussi fait surtout pour ça
c'était pour montrer que la clarinette
c'est quand même un très bel instrument
enfin forcément moi ça ne m'a pas si on
met pour montrer au grand public ce
qu'on peut faire la clarinette simon a
en effet remporté le titre grâce à son
interprétation de claix dinars danse de
martin frost c'est un morceau assez
réputé en clarinette quand même qui est
très dures techniquement mais qui est
très très plaisant à jouer est très
dynamique et donc j'ai tout de suite
accepté cette proposition
la préparation de l'émission a
représenté des heures de travail aux
côtés de son professeur au conservatoire
de genève qui a suivi de près ses
prestations télévisées connaissaient le
résultat mais mais en voyant en direct
jamais le trac pour maintenant je suis
aussi dit j'espère qu'il n'y a pas une
erreur jusqu'au dernier moment et et
c'est émouvant
avec désormais une bourse en poche et
l'enregistrement de son premier album
sur le point de débuter simmons ouvre
les portes d'un bel avenir musical après
son bac il prévoit de se présenter aux
concours d'entrée des meilleures écoles
de musique française et suisse
voilà dans ce journal après la musique
la littérature
avec la rencontre d'un passionné de
jules verne vous allez le voir qui a
adapté son célèbre roman le tour du
monde en 80 jours en bande dessinée et
qui nous explique en quoi l'auteur était
si exceptionnel au micro de diane le
moisson de lmtv sarthe il s'agit de
stéphane chesnais regarder jules verne
n'est jamais cité les portes brevet des
collèges il est pas au baccalauréat dans
les années 60 on l'appelait le romancier
de la science fiction bien non non c'est
un vulgarisateur ils avaient toutes les
données de l'époque et les a transmis
vingt ou cinquante ans après ce qui
allait se produire et il s'est pas
trompé parce que y lisait tous de la
bibliothèque d'amiens à l'époque toutes
les revues qui était technique ou
scientifique
il les étudiait toutes voilà et nous
aurons une page sports dans ce journal
plus précisément une page consacrée au
football il n'aura pas fallu beaucoup de
temps à l'as monaco pour se doter d'un
nouvel entraîneur aussitôt niko kovac
licenciés aussitôt philippe clément
embaucher l'entraîneur belge de 47 ans
va devoir relever de nombreux défis dont
celui de faire entrer l'équipe dans le
top 5 de la ligue 1 un sujet de yannick
de bever pour monaco un fou regarde
les résultats
voilà pourquoi niko kovac yeux n'est
plus l'entraîneur de monaco 2022 au delà
d'un parcours européen sur lequel il n'y
a rien à redire qualifié pour les
huitièmes de finale d'europa league
c'est bien la position des monégasques
en ligue 1 qui faisait grimacer les
dirigeants rouge et blanc
sixièmes à trois points du podium certes
mais à 17 unités du paris saint-germain
wild bunch of life
et
9,1
il faut we need is
art
le belge n'en est qu'à l'aube de sa
carrière d'entraîneur alors pourquoi lui
en partie parce que ces trois dernières
années il a remporté le championnat
belge avec genk d'abord puis bruges ce
qui fait du flamand le meilleur coach de
belgique son style de jeu et audacieux
attractif et surtout il fait confiance
aux jeunes fleuristes et fait nouveau
et
aceproject
[Musique]
n'empêchait quick l'italie sait
exploiter le plein potentiel de monaco
voici donc le défi de philippe clément
en ligue 1 face au fc nantes au stade de
la beaujoire
je vous le disais dans les titres de ce
journal les interminables embouteillages
pourrait bientôt être de l'histoire
ancienne grâce aux taxis volant que vous
voyez sur ces images de michael joly et
d'angélique bois l'aide via 95 pour
l'instant en phase de test nous
pourrions voir voler ces engins dans le
ciel d'île de france à l'occasion des jo
de paris en 2024 prix estimé d'une
course une centaine d'euros quand même
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur nos chaînes de la tnt en région et
sur tv5 monde on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]